what's up everybody we are celebrating
galentine's day
oh that was nice savannah um and anyway
i thought that i would celebrate with my
bff trisha
[Music]
we've known each other i think for over
15 years
um since 2005 i think we discussed which
is a long time it's a long
that's my longest relationship for sure
anyway so we're gonna see we know each
other pretty well
and we're around each other pretty well
we even have moments where like we need
to
be a part because we finish each other's
sentences there we go
we're gonna answer these questions we're
gonna see how well we know each other
you'll get it i don't need to explain
the rules you're not idiots and if you
are we'll catch up
describe the worst date i've ever been
on i haven't
been on a 10 dates like like all in or
all out
okay okay so the worst date talk about
the worst date i've ever been on okay
mine is talked about his ex the entire
time oh
or the short guy
the guy talked about his height too much
and she left after saying she was he was
i was going to bed
but i was thinking it's either he talked
about his ex or he talked or he
was too short yeah that guy talks about
his ex told me to go out for drinks
and then we go out for drinks and then
i'm like why didn't you get a drink he's
like oh my ex didn't like when i drank
and i was like
chef please i'm just like why
are we and then the whole yeah we were
nailing this at the time
what does kelly do that makes me laugh
um
that's a hard one oh you're writing a
book okay
what do you do that makes me laugh at
her oh and i think
hey um let's see i'm so hysterical
you are all the time i don't know
something specific you do
[Laughter]
we're gonna have to oh i can't really
think of it there's some stuff i can't
say
too i didn't say anything like that i
know
this is like a funny to me
that's supposed to be funny oh you're
still this oh
that's what we just talked about she's
still just writing oh my god we're
so gonna have a second answer
okay okay what's yours says she's not
going to talk about the book
she breaks it back up
but really what
that was my first answer but then i was
like she's not gonna say that okay cool
name three things we 100 agree on oh
that's pressure i mean we agree on a lot
of things i don't know the three shows
um no i can't see that one either
[Laughter]
oh i can't put that either because this
is on tv okay um
okay um hmm okay
okay what's yours dogs are awesome
we are hashtags
[Laughter]
what is my biggest pet peeve i probably
should have
said that differently okay liars oh
[Laughter]
say what you mean mean what you say
have a nice day i think we kind of know
that i think we
did all right
i don't know because it's fun thank you
for hanging with us um
if you're not you know in love or it's
not working out
then you're having a great valentine's
day call a friend it'll be fun
all right bye yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever